[Music]
Rocky Mountain spotted fever a
mysterious and usually fatal disease was
often called Mountain fever will death
for black measles
it was much feared by early settlers of
the Rocky Mountain region the brown
areas denote the counties from which one
or more cases had been recognized and
reported as early as nineteen five it
was especially dreaded in western
Montana where four of every five victims
died
some people are convinced that the
poison is in frigid water
others say it is given off by decaying
sawdust and pine needles a few Indians
believe
it comes from the tick bite mr. Hawkins
swears his boy got it from being near
bear grass blossoms last June
it took a doctor almost three days to
reach here it was too late
stimulated by Montana health authorities
scientists of national repute began
experiments that brought exciting hope
spotted fever transmitted by woodtick
researchers had just completed an
experiment that opens the field for an
effective battle against this terrible
disease dr. HT Ricketts used the blood
from a spotted fever patient to infect
experimental tick hosts he permitted the
suspected vector derma Center and asami
to take a blood meal from the infected
guinea pigs
now would the ticks from an infected
host be infected and would they transmit
the infection to a normal host
the suspects did transmit spotted fever
these abandoned buildings immediately
became laboratories the federal-aid and
Ra coolies Montella program were now
joined against a dangerous disease that
challenged a coordinated effort for four
decades the initial studies concentrated
on the biology and possible control of
the tick
tick flagging originated with these
early workers and there's still a most
effective technique for collecting the
woodtick thermos center and a sony was
found to infest both small and large
animals and to have a two year lifecycle
spring hatched larva the first of two
immature stages were found drawing blood
from small animals these transformed to
nymphs who go into hibernation from late
summer until the following spring
the second spring a second stage the
nymphal ticks feed on small animals also
infected lava or nymphs were found to
infect their hosts whose blood then
became infectious for simultaneously
feeding ticks these will transform to
adults by late summer then hibernate
in the third spring which completes the
two-year cycle the adults feed on large
animals and man
infected ticks feeding on the small or
large animals do not cause obvious
illness the male has a mottled gray
color pattern before engorgement this
female was a dark reddish brown they
mate while feeding either sex may
transmit the disease each female
deposits 6,000 to 8,000 eggs on the
ground the larvae from these may be
infected and maintain their infection to
adulthood
the disease is usually transmitted to
man by adult ticks of which about 1% are
infected
a tick host rodent control program was
initiated in a severely affected section
of western Montana in 1911 poisoned
grain killed the rodents essential to
the survival of the immature ticks
this program reduced the tick population
and was continued for about 20 years
until more effective disease control
appeared an extensive livestock dipping
program was also maintained this was a
direct attack on the adult ticks these
and minor control measures were
effective what could only be afforded in
limited areas this was a typical tick
control era setting
it was in this laboratory that the first
investigator became fatally infected
the bacteria like infectious agent was
found in all tissues of the tick
a stained preparation of infected tissue
shows the red stained agent
taxonomically designated Rickettsia
Rickettsia virulent strains killed
guinea pigs in seven to 14 days the
scrotum and foot pads became inflamed
these tissues finally died an autopsy
shows testes inflamed and adherent to
body wall
spleen enlarged
and lymph nodes enlarged
in 1921 investigators moved to a vacated
country schoolhouse where another
heartening breakthrough was made by
doctors Spencer and Parker spotted fever
vaccine found spotted fever vaccine
proven immunity through vaccination
seems assured basically the vaccine was
made by grinding the highly infected
adult ticks in a phenol solution
handset Breguet ssin removed the course
tissue clear vaccine contains the killed
immunity producing Raquette see a
kitchen pressure cooker was used for a
sterilizing autoclave
an alcohol lamp for flaming and a
syringe for bottling the vaccine
19:25 first years output thousands
exposed 34 vaccinated research expanded
rapidly after 1928 when the state of
Montana provided the first safe modern
facility
a tick destroying parasite was now
introduced to supplement the current
rodent poisoning and stock dipping
control programs this parasite under
Ellis for karai deposits eggs in the
nymphs by a stinging action the maggot
stage of this parasite killed the
engorged nymphs by consuming their hosts
internal organs after a pupil stage they
emerge as adult parasites ready to
parasitize other nymphs millions of
these parasites were reared for release
near small tick hosts layers
although parasites were successfully
maintained in the laboratory no
parasitized nymphs could be collected
the following seasons
the startling recognition of spotted
fever in some eastern states suddenly
made this a nationwide problem
because of these pressures the federal
government purchased the Montana
facility a second unit was added in 1934
millions of highly infected ticks could
now be reared annually for increased
vaccine production but chemical grinders
facilitated mass production
a separatory funnel a sterile room
instead of the syringe for bottling
potency and sterility testing could now
be performed at the manufacturing
laboratory instead of at national
headquarters
after 15 years of use records
demonstrated the protective value of the
vaccine
in comparison with the production of
only enough vaccine for 34 immunizations
in 1925 there was no enough for use by
physicians throughout the nation by 1940
additional facilities made it possible
to accommodate more scientists and
broaden the research to include other
diseases in nature communicable to man
the diseases studied by then are noted
in the top line of each experimental
animal card
another milestone in the expanding
struggle against spotted fever was dr. H
R Cox's first time culturing of laquet C
in embryonic egg tissue Rickettsia
Raquette c could now be produced more
efficiently and it eliminated the stray
tick hazard eggs containing 8 day
embryos were inoculated with spotted
fever and incubated further highly
infected yolk sacs were harvested from
mechanically opened eggs
yoke's acts were blended and a phenol
formalin solution was added to kill and
preserve the Rikishi and fats were
extracted with ether
by now field information on ticks from
across the nation was needed to complete
epidemiological data on the various tick
borne diseases the entomologists found
many species some in the ground
some on trees and in the jungle as well
as in the desert information on their
taxonomic determination disease
transmission potential and distribution
were essential
three species were found to infect man
the woodtick
the dog tech
and the Lone Star tick
spotted fever is still an ever-present
danger to those who live in or visit
would tick infested areas
these are typical exposures to the
woodtick
exposure to the dog tick could of course
take place in the home the time of
greatest exposure to the tick is in the
spring and early summer that this tick
is infected contrary to common belief
the ticks mouthparts seldom remain
embedded in the skin after the specimens
removal influenza-like symptoms appear
about one week after the bite of an
infected tick serological diagnosis for
tick borne diseases was a routine
service at the rocky mountain laboratory
physicians also depended upon its
scientists for the most recent
information on these diseases one such
test was the wild Felix for spotted
fever
treatment was usually symptomatic in
other words major discomforts could be
alleviated but the disease would run its
course a rash usually appears on the
wrists and ankles sometime during the
first week
it soon covers the entire body in severe
cases it later becomes confluent when
the illness is fatal death usually
occurs during the second week of illness
non-fatal cases are bed fast two to
three weeks
vaccinations is advisable each spring
for those extensively exposed to ticks
in high incident areas it was made
available through free vaccination
clinics avoid the carriers may wait on
low vegetation do not wear clothing that
is open at the bottom
they are attracted by the body odor
under the garment to avoid bites each
garment should fit over the one above
even so the entire body and both sides
of the clothing should be thoroughly
examined before retiring once on the
neck it is usually felt before it
attaches the long-sought wonder cure
came in the late 1940s with the
commercial introduction of certain
antibiotics
they have greatly reduced the death rate
and the fear of this once dread malady
has essentially disappeared
spotted fever fought back for half a
century from wicked stick transmission
experiment to antibiotics and took the
lives of five researchers McClintock
McCrae Cowan
curly
to the memory of our fellow laboratory
workers who while engaged in the study
of Rocky Mountain spotted fever have
contracted the disease and died as after
the victory over other historically
notorious infectious diseases these
costs are now being repaid the
developments and knowledge gained have
made fatal spotted fever cases the
exception and eliminated the universal
fear it is no longer a disease of
mystery
[Music]
you